金ちゃん肇社長ですというわけで以前ですねあずっと指つがあったやつを取り除くとき
の下になったゴリラクリニックさんにまた来ております8月1日から新しくスタート
するなんかあるらしいんですよ
すごいのがどんなものかといいますと皆さん夏ってやっぱプールと海とか行くと思うん
ですけども同じかと筋肉
君になりませんかてなんかもう
たくさんお腹の筋肉にキックんだか素晴らしいのがあるらしいので今回それをちょっと
受けてみて
大キ針の復旧適してモテモテの体でライトプールに行こうと思いますね外交
すすめですアクセシブルよろしくお願い致します綺麗になりました
秘境預けて頂き施術が苑主たるぷとという
いきたいはい m スカルプトというのはですね筋肉を増強させながら脂肪を燃焼して
いくことで理想的な体を作っていくポイント施術になり
簡単に言いますと30分間前に満開腹筋をしたのと同じような高
あっはに挽回を切るでた左が増えをする深さなんですけれども
0.7cm くらいまでですねシャーシます
強力に筋肉を収縮していた
なるほどねヴァニタスかいいねうーん
結構痛みもあるんですけれども収縮の痛みはあるんですがこちらはの医療機関でのに
入って使っている
はいの効果に関しては2番回分の腹筋をしたときのあの痛みが狂う
そうですねわざとけっこ筋肉痛のような痛みもくるんです
も日常生活には特に制限だ言って頭ブランドと一般に市販されているは dms と
言ったけどあの場所だったという
塗るやつですですねその機械の約10億倍のえええ
10億倍すげぇこんな数字が聞けるとは
にか施術に関しては5匹もんだぞ
チョコナイトプールに行きたいですよろしくお願いしますじゃあ初めて入ったじゃろ
はいちょっと外してえっとちょっとズボンし下げてもらうんですけどもこちら玉井さん
向けですね
イケメンですいやそれがやる前と思うんですよ最近ちょっと筋トレしてるんで
雑感兆しが見えるから暗いんだだいたいこんなもんですやる前は
これがよりこれを使うことでよろしく
また場所の挑戦ちょっとするかもしれないっ
まずテストからはい味を流しているのでちょっと優しいものから帰れん
いいんじゃないん
[音楽]
あっはぁあんっ
もうもうもう1まレンダー
ハーイが全然余裕ですよ
7これは何と抹茶についたりするんですねそうですね
道民なって知っまぁこれで only ぐっでこれからこんなとこれがもう強くて長い
なぁ全然よぷっ
ぞ
これでもまだウォーミングアップですねぇー
ああああああ
悪くないねぇ一けど聞いたり感じがすごいしますっ
いつ頃やるわっそれを理解し損なんでちょっとあげちゃいますと全然ででもう
ああああああ
goo
不本意じゃ枚争われるううううううっ
すっごいヒョンまだ払ってくれるってこと
取れそうですねいけそうですねー
ています
主は井山やはやまとうたリスクはいた
また痛い8悪い
グラインドでてるッ
いやもう全然尺できましょう激安館でもやるだろやっぱねの
挙げてみましょう4月からまだを磨くんです
いや悪くないんだユーザー
さあ
いや全然余裕でさぁ
演武言うんですよやりたかった
言えばいいよああ
ニッのためなぁ
ran
ana
ます
[音楽]
rar
ああっ9聞いたら呼吸系ですねーこれはなくこれなんかですねわりかし
幸せがともらう
[音楽]
me
起きるけどダメだーかーらー
んですけど
tu
[音楽]
me
pr
[音楽]
最初より慣れてますかなるといろんなれてますよね
moon
ありがとうございまーんつかれさまでした
やばいもうズボンが全身やせ負けです
はいというわけで腹筋30分の2万回分行ってきました
でもパッと見で結構なが引き締まっちゃってる気がするんですよね行こうか出るのか
ちょっと後時間差でも全然出るらしいんですけどもこれを週1回に4回やると思う
ましてなるのではないかなと思っております最初マーズでやばいですもなんか腹筋を
100回高速でやらされという気分だったんですけども徐々になれって空軍で多分誰か
なと思いました
素敵な復帰が手に入りたい人はぜひゴリラクリニックで受けてみてください
来週も行こう
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ